all right guys bang-bang
I've got taste Shawn here lots of stuff
going on we invested in named bass a
while ago pre handshake named bass
launching and it's live it is game on
but let's first talk about your
background and kind of what you did pre
crypto and then we'll get into into
what's going on with the handshake yeah
totally I have a bit of a
non-traditional background basically I
got my career started a company called T
Spring which was really big while ago so
it's still pretty big actually but
they're a custom apparel selling
platform was an engineer there and
actually left high school to work there
left high school left high school yeah
you left high school after your
sophomore year all right what was the
logic behind leaving high school as a
sophomore yeah so there it was it was
pretty crazy because I'm from Boston but
I detailed the CEO and I got an
internship there for the summer and at
the time they're doing a million dollars
in revenue every day yeah so it was just
blowing out like that was coming through
Facebook I think mostly through Facebook
yeah so it was just an insane amount of
revenue and growth and it's just like
empowering people to be their own like
entrepreneurs effectively so I saw that
opportunity as like I really wanted to
work there and get the experience so it
convinced my school let me take like a
gap year effectively between my
sophomore and junior year and then I
worked at T spring for that year
full-time what was the biggest takeaway
yeah I mean they say was that I can do
something yeah I want to do that is
ambitious and and so we pretty got it it
was pretty you know it's pretty
non-traditional kind of some people kind
of thought I was crazy like they didn't
think it was a good idea and then ended
up working out so I think like taking
the bet on myself was something that I
kind of internalized that's one of my
favorite things to tell people is just
bet on your [ __ ] self man yeah
it's one of these things where when you
bet on yourself if you succeed you win
if you bet on yourself and you fail you
can sleep at night yeah hit like the
worst thing in the world would be to be
in that situation want to go do it not
do it and then every night be worried
about you know damn should I have done
it and so what what year is this that
you did this was 2014
okay so 2014 I'm at Facebook I'm running
the growth team Oh Facebook pages and
teespring was absolutely killing us
because they were doing all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] on Facebook and it was one of
those things were like it's good because
someone's super excited on Facebook but
they were also doing things I think
teespring was the one who was taking
people's last names yeah hated t
straight guys that was huge at the time
so what teespring was doing which was
very smart was they would basically run
an ad and in the ad they would pull the
users last name and then insert that
last name on to the t-shirt image and
then put that in the ad all dynamically
so I would see like Papa Leone Oh family
rocks t-shirt yeah oh [ __ ] like that's a
cool t-shirt right the problem is that
not everyone is dumb like me and some
people are like hey dude that's creepy I
think we had to like literally change
the rules on the advertising system to
prevent using last names and all kinds
of stuff but T sprinkle is very very
innovative and cutting-edge when it came
to all that stuff yeah that was and it
wasn't necessarily teespring
specifically it was the the
entrepreneurs on teespring a lot of them
were these like affiliate marketers and
those guys were really creative in terms
of what they what they would be because
the teespring system if I remember
correctly is essentially allows me to
couple with a design post the design I
don't have to touch t-shirts I don't
touch supply chain I don't touch payment
processing anything I can just put my
design up and then people can come in
and buy and teespring takes care of
everything or exactly yes super smart
all right so you do that would you do it
again hundreds everything I mean
everything really worked out so
I think in a parallel universe things
wouldn't have worked out and like that
that risk was pretty capped and hers of
what would happen if I didn't like it I
would go back to school after that year
I'd be a year older
you know I'd still go back down the
traditional path but I didn't have to do
that because at the end of that gap year
I ended up sending a starting company
with my friend who was a teal fella at
the time and we got into Y Combinator so
what was the company strong intro so
that was a recruiting startup we
basically how tech companies grow their
engineering team through employee
referrals now that's probably the best
way to grow your early team and then we
ended up getting into what was you might
have remembered that the YC fellowship
which was like a short experiment that
they started when we were in the first
batch we actually the first company
accepted into that it was like 20 out of
6500 applicants and from there we got
into the core Y Combinator program and
that's when I officially dropped out of
school to do that because you know
people tried multiple years in a row to
get into YC it was like a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
to me YC is probably actually better
than high school if you know you want to
go build companies right like like that
education that you get in kind of
practical application is gonna be much
more applicable to your life than going
in sitting in 11th grade math yeah like
what uh I was talking to somebody
recently and I was in like the basic
classes but sometimes like yeah like you
remember I think about trigonometry No
right like maybe some algebra you
remember but other than that there's a
lot of education that goes that's kind
of more generalized and for people who
don't know what they want to do that's
really valuable right but for people who
know hey it's what I want to go do
something like a YC probably more
valuable to them right I agree hundred
percent yeah all right
let's get into what you're doing today
is all built on and around handshake
but before we talk about handshake I
want to talk about kind of the legacy
website domains and kind of technology
stack so walk us through how do these
naming services work how to DNS is work
like how do you think about that
infrastructure that currently is based
in the one that we know us today
yeah it's really
fascinating fascinating actually because
DNS the domain name system its
infrastructure that powers the entire
internet right every time you type in
google.com or facebook.com you're using
DNS but it's basically technology that
was duct-taped together and and barely
works effectively the reason why is
because when it was started no one
really assumed that the internet would
get as big as it would get right there
was that famous Nobel prize-winning
economist who was like the whole Krugman
yeah yeah there's that you know it'll
never get that big it'll be like one
company or whatever banners and then it
blew up so the internet DNS
infrastructure it has basically not
scaled with the usage of Internet and
the importance of it the way it works
today is it's basically a tree hierarchy
you have T L DS and the root zone TLDs
are top-level domain names so an example
of that is calm org net and then each of
those TL DS are owned by an organization
or an entity Verisign for example owns
calm and so let's go real slow here
because I think this was a really
important part so a TLD is a top-level
domain that calmed org whatever is
actually owned by somebody yeah right so
Verisign for example is a private
company yes
alright so Verisign owns calm and so
they just when they bought calm or how
did they come into ownership of calm
yeah it was kind of a weird situation
but they basically had ownership over
calm and then when I can try it like
there's there's some like controversy
and then they like sue them so I get the
rights to it or whatever so there's a
lot of controversy but basically there's
a long history but now they own calm and
they basically are able to charge
everyone who buys a domain name you know
a few dollars like five ten dollars
every year so the top-level domain is
the dot-com or GDU dot whatever right
when I buy google.com facebook.com it
cetera the Google the Facebook the you
know whatever comes before the dot-com
what is that called yeah so that is a
second-level domain okay a second-level
domain yeah and those are and those are
what you get to buy
got it and so if I buy let's say all of
a sudden I found google.com through one
of these website you know services that
sell domain names am I I could buy
google.com from Google right kind of the
person who currently owns the
second-level domain or if no one's ever
owned it before I would be buying it
from Verisign is that right
yeah it's actually an intermediary in
front of air sign so there's this
another particular system participant
called a registrar
okay domain registrar and they're they
basically work with Verisign and they're
able to register dot-com domains and and
they pay Verisign a cut and then they
usually charge a little bit of margin on
top of that okay so when I'm buying
through GoDaddy or one of these domain
services I'm either buying from the
person who currently owns it who's
another corporation individual whoever
or I'm buying it through a registrar who
is basically acting for Verisign and
they're splitting the revenue from that
yeah exactly and GoDaddy would be the
registrar in that case okay so as that
system has worked for you know decades
now who comes up with more top-level
domains right like since calm then there
was like dotco now you could pretty much
buy all kinds of top-level domain or
second-level domains for those top
levels who comes up with those
so it's this entity called the ICANN and
they effectively assigned the new TLDs
and they decide who gets which TLD it
was actually used to be run by the US
government and then they basically spun
that out as like a non-profit because
other countries were uncomfortable with
the US government having that much power
but the ICANN Estelle a US based
organization they're based in LA and
they decide who gets which G's got it
so I'm already seeing some issues here
with the registrar's I can't
etc I'm assuming that they have a pretty
good oversight in governance over this
system even after you've bought the
second-level domain yeah yeah they're
they're basically there's like a
significant number of rules that each of
the TLD owners have and then the TLD
owners are able to basically extract
I'll enforce policies on the domains
that are sold and they're able to revoke
them or seize them or shut them down and
then I can as well has a lot of
discretion in terms of how they manage
the issuance of new TLDs
and also existing TLD so for example the
ICANN recently lifted the price caps on
comm domains like this happened just two
days ago and those domains are now gonna
become 70% more expensive over the next
decade what would you say a price cap
what does that mean so before there was
a limit on how much Verisign could
charge for each domain and that was just
removed
what was that limit do you know I forget
the exact $10 were like $100 it was it's
as a percentage like how much you can
increase the percentage price Scot a
year got it all right and so in this
system when I can hand out the top-level
domains how do they choose who gets to
own the top-level domain
yeah that seems like a situation ripe
for either corruption or influence or
something it's really funny you point
that out because it is a corrupt system
it sounds like there's a nonprofit
that's handing out a basically free
product to somebody and that person can
turn around to make a lot of money with
it so I can imagine there's jockeying
for who receives it so there is this
huge controversy recently because I can
try to sell org which is okay you you
know obviously one very popular most
popular TLD is in the world and they
basically sold it for a very cheap price
to a private equity firm that was that
had no other participants and the
auction it was just a private deal with
that private equity firm and it was run
by the ex-ceo of ICANN so the private
equity firm that bought it yeah is run
by the ex-ceo of ICANN yeah we're
strongly affiliated it was partners of
the ex-ceo so it basically just reeks of
corruption there is a huge uproar on the
internet about it and it's still not
settled they still might be able to sell
org to that private equity so so let's
say that worst-case scenario is
corruption best-case scenario it's
favoritism
raise that probably accurate yeah but
it's it's hard it's a hard pitch to even
frame it as favoritism it's a lie it's
pretty corrupt cuz the the entire deal
basically was like everything was done
behind closed doors there was not a
period for other bidders to come in it
was just done with that one private
equity firm as a deal so it's pretty
hard to even frame it as favoritism its
I can't
previously owned org they basically to
determine it's a complicated situation
but they kind of help determine where it
goes okay and so do you remember what
the purchase price is around like a
billion or something so for only a
billion dollars you could own dot org
and every time somebody buys a dot org
domain essentially you're getting a cut
of that transaction exactly yeah I'm
assuming that they make more than a
billion dollars a year doing that the
it's it's actually less than a billion
dollars per year but you you basically
do the discounted cash flow but the
thing that they did not include in it
was right before the private equity firm
bought it they got I can to lift the
price caps on the door domain so the
valuation was based on the previous
revenue and then they lifted the price
cast and they got it for an extreme
discount effectively got it yeah sounds
pretty sketchy yeah alright so the old
world we understand we all use it some
of us understand the technical component
some of us just you have these or
experience by typing in a kind of human
readable URL and then handshake comes
along talk to me about what exactly is
handshake kind of what are they trying
to build who's behind it on that yeah so
handshake is a new protocol that is
effectively putting these TL DS on a
blockchain
the easy way to think about it is
functionally it's actually very similar
to Bitcoin it's a proof of work based
chains
it has utx O's and all that but instead
of using the coins as money use the
coins register names on the handshake
blockchain and these names are T ologies
so anyone can register their own TLD on
handshake it works through this Vickrey
auction complete
on chain and the benefit of having this
Tod on chain is that one the entire
issuance process is decentralized right
so you don't need an ICANN to determine
who gets what it's just an open system
and the TLD being on chain makes it very
very difficult for these names to be
seized or censors it also makes the
issuance very private you don't need to
go and reveal your identity when you're
buying these domains effectively and
then it also improves it provides a set
function improvement in the security and
I have to get a little bit more into the
technical details but basically when you
type in like HTTPS into your browser
there's an entire system that manages
that and that system is not very secure
today and the handshake is effectively
providing a more secure system for this
okay so handshake has rebuilt the domain
system that is going to be based on a
blockchain and that domain system has a
couple of key differences right and you
just name some of them so one of them is
now there's a decentralized kind of
assignment process so I can can't go to
the ex-ceo of ICANN and say hey you get
that org yeah
and that decentralized process really is
this Vickrey auction right and as I've
learned more about this what's
interesting to me is that rather than
say hey handshakes launching which it
just did here's every single name that
could possibly be available what they're
doing is they're essentially just
releasing a kind of infrequently a
couple at a time right and so you may
like let's say for me if I want you know
dot I don't know dot Bitcoin right I
can't just go today and buy it I've got
to wait for dot Bitcoin as the top-level
domain on handshake become available but
that may not happen for months or
whatever right yeah exactly so handshake
basically learned from predecessors and
previous naming attempts and there are a
few key differences that basically
helped me build conviction that
handshake could succeed one is it's not
replacing the entire DNS system is just
replacing the root zone so just the
hierarchy at the top everything else is
actually pretty decentralize
already but basically it's very focused
in terms of what it's trying to improve
and then the other issue is you know
early adopters getting to bid on all the
good names in previous attempts and you
know basically squatting on an every
good name so the names are rolled out
over the course of 52 weeks any name is
available for bidding and will be
available for bidding at some point over
the 52 weeks but if you come on day one
you only have you know 1 over 52 of that
entire namespace got it ok and so in
this auction process let's say that dot
bitcoin name in week 14 becomes
available right now I'm making this up
but in week 14 you and I both want it we
essentially are going into a system
we'll get to what those systems can be
and we're gonna bid a monetary amount to
get it whoever has the highest bid wins
yes exactly got it and so this is a
pretty good way to do price discovery
yeah right yeah and then remind me a
Vickrey auction is basically I put a
here's the most amount of money I'm
willing to pay and every other
participant does that and then I if I'm
the winning bid I just pay one dollar
more than the last second highest bid
you just pay exactly the second highest
bid okay so so let's say I say I'm
willing to pay $10,000 for not Bitcoin
everyone else is less than 10,000 the
second highest bid was 9,500 I pay 9,500
because I was willing to pay more but I
just have to pay what exactly yeah and
it very interesting okay so why exactly
does the dns need a blockchain right as
kind of you think about what handshakes
built likewise a blockchain necessary
that's a great question and there's a
few reasons why blockchain is helpful in
this case
honestly when you're talking with
developers and those are probably the
people that you really most strongly
need to convince with something as
technical as handshake the key reason is
actually security so blockchains
at least today are like pretty
inefficient they're difficult to use
there's a lot of negatives when it comes
to using them when in comparison to a
normal database but the thing that
they're really good at is basically
trust right they are trust minimizing
and in systems where you don't want to
have a single entity in control of that
trust they're really good at solving
that
so in the traditional system the way
that security is on the TLS which
determines HTTP basically that system is
managed by this group of entities called
a certificate authority
so these certificate authorities
basically determine the security of the
Internet today and hand those secretive
certificate authorities are very
vulnerable to hacking and they can be
compromised very easily because the way
it works is that when you visit a
website which it with HTTPS if any one
of these certificate authorities that
are involved in that system gets
compromised and there are there are
thousands of them then your Internet
traffic is compromised so it's like a
one of many failure system and instead
what handshake is saying is instead of
using these two difficulties let's shift
the trust to this distributed blockchain
and instead of this like one of many
system you need the entire block chains
be basically be compromised in order for
the security to be compromised so that
is the key insight for handshake of why
is providing a step function improvement
in the security its shifting the route
of trust from certificate authority
based system to a distributed ledger
that is basically backed by the
blockchain got it and into do I prove my
ownership of the root domain or come to
top-level domain like how does that work
yeah so it basically works like owning
Bitcoin you have a private key and a
wallet and as long as you control the
private key for that domain you own that
domain and only you can update the
records or remove it or do anything with
it so you know outside of security there
are additional benefits that come from
being on the blockchain which is that
you can truly own your domain name you
know most people don't realize that
they're only renting domain names when
they buy them today so you're you're
effectively only a renter you're not an
owner and that's why you have to keep
paying on an annual basis exactly you
got it with handshake you can truly own
your domain name and no one can seize
that from you and also for the end users
that are trying to resolve it right
you're trying to type in google.com
Google com doesn't work in every
jurisdiction it's very easy to basically
do DNS censorship China yeah exactly and
handshake just makes that significantly
more difficult to censor so you by being
on the blocking you get this
of true ownership you get the privacy
but you also get access because now end
users anywhere around the world can
access your name effectively got it and
so part of this system that's
interesting to me is if I can now be
that private equity firm that owns org
or I can own dot-com or dot Bitcoin or
whatever and I truly own it can I sell
you as somebody else a second-level
domain so like could if I owned dot
Bitcoin could I then turn around on
handshake and sell somebody else like
pump Bitcoin or tayshaun dot Bitcoin etc
yeah you totally can got it and so
really by getting a top-level domain I
could essentially be getting a business
right where I'm able to kind of cut up
the second-level domains and then sell
those off as individual assets to people
who want to use those do they own the
second-level domain or they just renting
the second-level domain yeah so and that
system it actually depends on how you
construct it okay there's a role in
which you even create a sidechain
effectively on top of your top-level
domain that you own and that can be its
own completely decentralized system
because this is all managed on a
blockchain you can you know basically
write technology that makes it very
decentralized or you can go to
traditional route where you say okay I
owned a Bitcoin or let's say I owned you
know dot pump and I want to sell all
these second-level domains and there's
like a busiest system that you can plug
into that makes that very easy and you
can go and sell those domains so you can
run that on business and what we've seen
is that you know there are other
companies in the space that are selling
these you know specific extensions for
those domains and they're they're doing
very well so effectively what handshake
enables is anyone can build their own
business like that I still saw that
start selling these domains how long ago
did handshake launch a week ago a week
ago
there's rap song a week ago a week ago
what's the highest price someone's paid
for a top-level domain so far yeah so
we've yet to see that because right now
we're still in the mining period of
handshake basically they the the network
has a limit on transactions for the
first two weeks to allow for a
sufficient mining capacity to come
to handshake gaaaah and right now it's
great because there's significant like
interest in handshake so I think the
current mining rate Israel something
like fifteen like Tara yeah I know coin
mine which people know I'm quite quite
fond of an investor they actually
enabled I think they were they were one
of the first ones they enabled their
consumer devices to mine handshake yeah
right on day one exactly yeah they
support as well so basically after this
two-week period then the registration is
open up and that's when you can start
bidding on these domain names and so
what we have for all of our users is
they've already started adding these
names that are watchlist so that they
get notified and they can automatically
go and bid so there's a lot of
excitement there all right you're not
part of the name of the handshake
business right you're not on their
engineering team you're building a
completely separate company called name
base what does that do yeah totally so
name base is the answer just server
what's clear we are investors I'm just
leading him yeah so basically name base
is what we do is we built a domain
registrar on top of handshake and then
on-ramp for handshake so in order to
participate in these options you need to
use H and s to do it and that's the
handshake token that's a handshake token
and the actual process is kind of
difficult to do it's kind of annoying
you have to be developer so what we
realize is we saw the potential of this
technology we want to make it spread as
fast as possible to as many people as
possible so we built tools to make it
easier to use so we have an on-ramp so
you can come on to your name base and by
H&S anywhere around the world and you
can use that HSN name base to bid on any
of these domain names so we have a GUI
that makes it really easy an easy way to
think about name is conceptually is
we're kind of like a combination of
GoDaddy and coinbase got it so right now
if I want to buy HMS which is the
handshake token and I need HMS to buy a
top-level domain or you guys the only
place I can get it yeah yeah okay so
only place I can get it right now is on
name base once I get HMS after this
two-week kind of waiting period for the
mining capacity to come online then I
can actually go
Bitcoin or whatever top-level domains
are available exactly yeah and I would
also note that the way that we enabled
that right now we're the only liquid
exchange for HS is basically we we were
aware of this two week my name only
period is so we partnered with miners
actually my name pools that they mined
directly into name base and so we're
able to sell that H&S now even when it's
not available anywhere else got it and
so if I buy that
top-level domain Bitcoin can I then turn
around and sell my second-level domains
to other people through name base or
we'll have to look good somewhere else
yeah you will eventually be able to do
that right now
that infrastructure hasn't been built
out got it okay and so what does this
become right like when I think about
kind of the web infrastructure it makes
a ton of sense to have domains that are
hard to censor that are hard to take
down etc and there's a number of people
working on this right hand shaking name
base there's on some whole domains etc
what is kind of the endgame here do we
replace the entire internet with these
kind of decentralized domain systems or
is there kind of coexistence like how do
you think about that yeah the way that I
see this adoption happening happening is
there is a sense of coexistence
basically what what I expect is that
handshake is going to eat TLDs shake is
going to be how new TLDs get issued
pretty much everyone on the world is
going to be on it eventually even if you
talk to existing dns people they kind of
see the potential here just because it's
very hard to solve the problems that
handshake solves without a blockchain
based technology so even if it's not
handshake eventually there will be a
blog blockchain based tool that does
this however there is a significant
amount of DNS infrastructure that's
already built out that the world relies
on and it is infeasible to just
completely replace all that so that is
why handshake is just replacing the root
zone which is where most of the problems
are so you get 90% of the benefit by
just replacing that with a blockchain
and all the second-level TLD domains and
that normal issuance and
governance process that can happen as
normal that just plugs into handshake so
what I expect is a handshake is going to
eat that but then everything else all
this existing infrastructure because we
have Pat dependency it's gonna keep on
being there right it's like why the New
York subway is still not super fast even
though Tokyo and trying to have a lot
faster subway systems so that existing
infrastructure is gonna stay there by
handshake is gonna replace the top level
root zone got it and then what's the
user experience like if I want to go to
one of these websites right so
somebody's bought a top-level domain
they've actually set it up etc can I
just go to my Google Chrome and type in
something to navigate there or do I need
to have some kind of special browser
like what's that user experience look
like yeah so there are multiple
different ways to use handshake but
effectively there's and it's also
dependent on your trust profile right
whether you want to use a third-party
tool or just run your own right kind of
like running a full node so effectively
what you can do is there are third-party
resolvers and we're partnering with a
few companies to make this really easy
that you can just use and it's
effectively similar to using a cloud
flare as one point one point one point
one or Google's 8.8.8.8 well what are
those yeah the cloud flare one point one
point one at one point one point one
point one so for ones for once for what
is that and 4/8 so basically these are
DNS resolvers that cloud flying google
respectively run and what they do is
basically they just make your your in
your dns resolution a little bit faster
and more private and also it's a little
bit more censorship resistant because
they unlock access to certain domains
that are blocked in certain countries so
these two resolvers already have
hundreds of millions of users and so
this is an existing behavior that people
have which is us point your dns to a new
resolver it takes like five seconds in
your computer or you can do it in your
router and then you're done and then
you're using that so handshake is the
same way handshake you just point your
dns to a handshake resolver and then
you're able to resolve these handshake
names and any computer that you use any
browser any computer etc as long as I've
pointed what you saved my router or your
computer or my computer yeah
the handshake resolver can I have
multiple resolvers that my computer's
pointed to yeah yeah you can like can I
can I use the regular Internet and also
go through this resolver at the same
time and like hey Yap multiple tabs open
and go back and forth that's a great
question so handshake is actually
completely compatible with the existing
Internet so that's that's one of the
things that give us conviction is
because you know if you're trying to go
and replace the entire internet with
this blocking based system and it's like
a whole new system that's basically
gonna yeah I have I have very little
conviction that such a system like that
would be able to succeed what Henry did
is they're compatible with the existing
system so all the normal domains that
you would access school comm
facebook.com segment do all those things
they will work as normal the existing TL
DS are all functional on handshake it's
just that the new TLDs are registered
through handshake are gonna be resolved
through handshake so when you're using a
handshake compatible resolver your
internet experience is basically only
improved because everything else works
as normal and just get access to this
new namespace effectively got it um what
do you think is the reason why this
couldn't work right you know obviously
you're bullish I'm bullish what are the
reasons or the biggest threats to it not
working yeah that's a great question and
I think the easiest way to identify
these issues is to look at what issues
have played previous attempts so first
of all you can't have any component of
the system be centralized it's kind of
similar to you know the Bitcoin
predecessors right how they always had a
central entity that effectively was shut
down by the government and so they never
took off and the Bitcoin basically
decentralized everything and then it you
know is eating up the world
same thing with handshake so there have
been alternative route zone attempts in
the past and their only value add is
that they're just like adding a new
namespace and that is not sufficient to
basically unseat the network effects of
the existing system so that is the first
component it needs to be fully
decentralized the other thing is that
the issuance of the names is incredibly
important to get right you don't want a
system where the early adopters and
Wales are able to buy up all the good
names because what you end up getting is
if when that happens and that has
happened
in previous naming attempts is that
someone comes in you know eight months
from now they are interested in the
system they see none of the good names
are available but also that system has
not you know basically taking the world
by stride yet and so why would you ever
invest in that system and buy into it if
you don't get access to the good names
and it's not even that valuable yet so
you really want to prevent these early
wheels from be able to able to squat all
the good names you want people allow
people who come in a little bit later to
still adopt it and get benefit from it
it's like digital real estate right you
want some of the good real estate to be
reserved so well Henrik did is they
created many mechanisms that effectively
helped prevent early adopters and whales
from getting all the good names you
still get an advantage that's inherent
in a good naming system but it's not
such an advantage that it's gonna kill
the system so that's that's basically
what worries
those are the mechanisms that handshake
has created to help mitigate failure but
you know we still haven't seen it work
out yet right it's you know handshaking
the name registrations haven't even
launched yet so there is a role that if
anything were to happen I would see that
mechanism not being as effective as we
thought it would now that could be a
potential cause for failure got it into
as you think through this who are the
people who are coming in first and
interested is it the people who are
traditionally squatting on domains and
used to kind of benefiting from
understanding the system yeah the
shocking thing for me is how diverse the
initial set of community members is so
some of our earliest adopters people
have been in our private beta for a
while because we were built on the
hendrik test net before
they're just crypto enthusiasts who are
basically true believers they kind of
see what's wrong with Internet they want
to improve it and they're super
interested in it and so is interesting
there because they're not only motivated
financially right they're going to
speculate on the coins and the names and
all that but they also believe in the
potential and I think that's like the
the true power of crypto right you have
this effectively a political or
philosophical cause and you can pair it
with an economic opportunity and the
combination or that is incredibly
powerful so we have those people we also
have just normal speculators we have
miners but we also have actual normal
domain errs as well so there is for
example one of our community members
Park do they're a very popular domain
registration site they basically like
you just like ordered IO domains ahead
of time and they're they're also in our
community so we have existing domain
brokers domain errs developers as well
and there's a few partnerships that
we're doing with people who are pretty
big in the developer community that
we're gonna be launching live pretty
soon so it's very varied but pretty much
everyone in the ecosystem who can be
interested is already interested which
is super cool to see from I am for sure
who's the team behind handshake because
it's pretty pretty impressive team if I
remember correctly right they previously
did something with the internet so it's
a weight home and that sounds really
ridiculous they worked on like core
infrastructure components the internet
rate yeah they're pretty involved with
Bitcoin early on so it's handshake in
general is at this point is a very
decentralized community so there
originally was a handshake foundation
that was put up and they actually raised
ten point two million dollars from
injuries and Horowitz Founders Fund
Sequoia
Greylock pretty much every investor in
Silicon Valley and they ended up
donating all that money away to
nonprofits and open-source developers
that's the most Silicon Valley I think
I've ever heard yeah they raised money
for their foundation but people didn't
get equity in anything and they turned
around and gave the money and donated it
all yeah exactly
okay yeah those investors got tokens
okay and the pre-sale but then they
literally didn't even use the money to
develop it and then the the people
behind that you know some of the people
involved were like personae Oh Joseph
poon who made lightning at work and
there's another Anjali who made private
Internet access but they were basically
only involved in the inception of it
they kind of kicked things off and then
now there's pretty much multiple
ecosystem participants that are all
involved in handshake there's us there's
another team called Oracle and there's
there's multiple developers there's a
developer community as well that's
that's basically not them and what we've
what basically we've seen is that the
handshake foundation at this point is
completely setting aside they basically
just launched it and they're letting it
out into the world if you go into the
handshake org website you'll see they
even say
everyone is a director of handshake like
little you can be a director I can shoot
you just have to say you're a director
of handshake it's not owned by anyone
there's no creator of handshake so if
anyone says their creator you know
they're just lying it's [ __ ] and
pretty much it's a very decentralized
unity that it's community driven at this
point got it and so when you think
through this like what keeps those
developers building on hand-shaker
because the way I think oh this is name
basis business is to facilitate the
buying and selling of H&S and then the
actual top-level domains and then
eventually it'll be a second-level
domains et cetera but you guys are
dependent on those developers staying in
the community building this and kind of
furthering what's being built like how
do you think about what that incentive
looks like yeah there's a few different
incentives that play here one is that
there's this really amazing air drop
mechanism that handshake built in they
basically recognized that for this thing
kind of thing to succeed you always need
the developers and so what they did was
basically there's a fully decentralized
era where the top 250,000 developers on
github are effectively eligible for this
airdrop and they can claim around 4,000
H&S and so that gives the developers an
economic incentive
it's an ALICE lee for developers like
usually they're like pretty well-off and
they're not that motivated by money
so really an easy way for them to play
around with the protocol and usually
with the the way that new technologies
are adopted is like you have developers
playing around with it on the weekend
and then it like becomes their like
full-time thing and they're like super
interested in it becomes like the thing
that everyone uses
same thing with Bitcoin Rises like
developer is playing around with it on
the weekend aetherium developer spinning
around on the weekend and now it's like
everywhere so there's this decentralized
our job that gives developers some skin
in the game and then the other reason is
that there's there are a lot of
developers who are if you know about DNS
if you're familiar with how the domain
name system works as a developer you're
pretty much going to be not happy with
how it works effectively so we get a lot
of people who are just like oh this is a
way for us this is like an incredible
improvement over the existing system and
it's a way for us they're just like
uncie I can or uncie these bad actors
that currently control the internet and
and effectively plague it they collect
rent on every one in the world so
there's a lot of interest just from that
and I think that's probably the the main
driving reason for developers being
said because typically developers are
more philosophically you know that that
is their more philosophically driven
than anything else right it's like the
entire open-source movement like why
would you contribute all your free time
on building this like you know writing
free software that anyone can use is
because they just believe in it you know
they have a cause they want to create
something for the world so that's really
the driving motivation for a lot of
these people why are you working on this
yeah so for me is is a kind of
interesting backstory you know I grew up
in the u.s. here so we don't really have
too many issues with censorship yet it's
gotten worse over time but you know
compared to the rest over old it's a
significant improvement so I never
really seen too much of this problem
firsthand however when I went to MIT
that's where I studied after starting
one to MIT who didn't go to high school
who didn't finish high school yeah yeah
I got I got pretty lucky how's that work
you supply maybe I should apply yeah let
me in there undergrad program yeah there
are like six year olds at MIT undergrad
so yes I already get an undergrad degree
somewhere else um sometimes it varies
like they're really like one of my
friends he was this guy from Canada who
he never finished high school he was
like a car mechanic for like six years
and he's like 28 and the one time I T
after he like applied and got in so I
think if you're interested in you're
like technologically interested as well
that's probably I would be dumb enough
to just apply get in and then drop out
the first day and say I dropped at MIT
yeah you so anyways when I was there um
you know one of the first things that I
did after one of the semesters was I
went and traveled to Turkey
my old roommate was Turkish I got to
travel with him and the thing that
struck me was not the cultural
differences because that's actually kind
of used to that with my roommate it was
when I try to visit a few like normal
web sites like Facebook or Twitter it
was blocked
I couldn't access it I got this like
blue screen like you know seized by
Turkish government or whatever and it
was shocking to me because you know I'd
grown up on YouTube and Twitter I
learned how to program on YouTube so I
wouldn't even have gone a job in the
first place if I had never had access to
those resources
and I basically realized that none of
those people in Turkey have access to
this or it's very very difficult for
them to get access you have to you know
jump through law hoops to basically
avoid the censorship that they have
that's one of the reasons why you know
cloth or googles resolvers are popular
actually in Turkey so I I saw that
problem but I also kind of didn't do
anything about it I was like I'm an
American like this isn't affecting me
what can I do as an individual and so I
didn't actually take action at that time
I just continued my trip and then I went
back to school and I didn't really think
about it but over the next you know few
years over the last few years what we've
seen is that the security and
sovereignty on the Internet is getting
worse and worse effectively you know I
grew up on an internet that was very
democratic right any web site in the
world you can access there's no borders
effectively and now what we're seeing is
that there the Internet is starting to
create its own borders and their
physical borders right is like China has
their own version of the internet it's
pretty closed off and they're not
exporting that to other countries Russia
is effectively creating their own
internet as well so what we're starting
to see is this a crazy trend where the
Internet is becoming more siloed over
time and you're starting to see this
insane amount of censorship you know in
India they're censoring a lot of regions
right now Spain they censored CIT which
is the Catalonian government's TLD when
they're trying to hold like a referendum
for independence so it's gotten worse
over time and has gotten more frequent
when I came across handshake I basically
saw the potential because I'm a generic
I could you know I was I was familiar
with some of the concepts that handshake
was trying to improve upon so when I saw
that I basically I was like oh shoot
like this technology is something that
can actually create a set function
improvement in how the implant works and
it would create an internet that is
global in democratic again anyone any
rock anywhere around the world can
resolve these names which is something
that is very difficult to do today and
so I saw the potential that for that and
I want to make a difference there and so
that's why I want to build name base
effectively is tooling an infrastructure
that makes handshake easier to use so
that the adoption can spread so one of
the things that's really interesting to
me and I don't know how this would work
but let's take right now in China for
example coronavirus is a huge topic and
there's been numerous examples of people
who either one have tried to raise
concerns and yeah there's a doctor who
got sick and in a passing away
there's I've recently read a story about
a gentleman who he went into a cities in
China and basically was a reporter he
was like a citizens reporter and he was
sharing videos and all stuff and then
all of a sudden he's disappeared and
they get people on the ground who are
taking videos and stuff and I saw a
video on Twitter I think was yesterday
that again I don't know how valid it was
or but in the video what was depicted is
basically they were visiting a woman and
saying hey you have to take down the
thing you posted on social media right
or you're gonna get in trouble
essentially and so what that brings to
is like there's this separation right
now I think the coronavirus scare and
kind of issue really highlights like
people outside of China don't know
what's going on there right and people
inside of China normally don't know
what's going on outside the US right so
it's kind of like we're now experiencing
a little bit of what they experience on
a daily basis but I'm wondering if
somebody in China could if they got
their hands on a top-level domain on the
handshake platform could they basically
set up a website and use that website to
publish information etc and then now
people outside the US or outside of
China and inside of China could all
access that website and now that
quote-unquote source of truth of what's
going on inside of China would be
available for anyone in the world to see
or there's still things with like the
Great Firewall exception that could
prevent that from happening yeah there's
actually a spectrum but effectively that
is a first step that you would have to
having a website that can't be shut down
by this Great Firewall and actually what
would probably end up happening is
basically there's our there's this
arbitrage period always because
governments are kind of late to adopt
technology we're just using handshake
alone with the normal internet is
sufficient but handshake is solving a
very specific layer of the existing
Internet infrastructure there's also
like the storage at layer and resolving
so you know the Great Firewall they do
like IP based filtering baby they even
do like packet filtering so like they're
they're censoring you based on like that
literally the data that you're sending
out so there is potential that they
would be able to do something like that
but when you pair handshake with as like
a primitive with something like saya
coin or ipfs or a file coin then you
have something that's that's very very
difficult to censor
so yes handshake would be able to do
that now and then basically it's always
a cat-and-mouse game so probably what
you would see is you know a few years
from now you wouldn't just use handshake
alone you use handshake with like this
ease and go yeah and it's really great
that you brought that up there's
actually a Ben Thompson article about
this recently you might you might you
probably like reading I'll send it you
after but effectively they talk he talks
about this is probably one of the the
strongest examples of why censorship
matters and it's really easy to explain
to anyone in the world right now
normally he says he wrote articles
specifically about corona virus yeah oh
wow yeah I would love read that yeah and
effectively what happened was the
doctors in China they knew about corona
virus early like they reported they they
BC saw a ton of patients start coming in
with SARS like symptoms and they're like
this is like new thing going on they're
really concerned about it they started
talking to other doctors about it and it
was this like phenomenon where they saw
like this was becoming an issue and this
is if I remember correctly in the news
they say like as early as like November
December yeah sure and we're talking you
know three four months ago yeah yeah so
they knew about it and they started to
raise the alarm bells and then the local
jurisdiction when governments were like
everything's yes they're like shut up
everything's under control there are
only like 49 patients that have this and
like the doctors they saw there's like
literally hundreds there are hundreds of
these patients coming in they're like
there's only 49 patients and their
symptoms are calm and then the initial
doctors who were spreading this news
they were punished their punishment was
like publicized - like everywhere it was
in the newspapers it was like these
doctors have been reprimanded and they
were spreading false news and don't
listen to them and basically what you
saw yeah it's crazy and what you saw was
every other doctor who was aware of this
problem now was silence right they
didn't have the the conviction they
didn't really have the ability to go and
share this because they knew that they
would also be silenced and they would
you know their families are at risk and
all this and
they didn't speak about it and the
consequence of that censorship is now
Karenna virus is spreading to the rest
of the world and it's getting worse and
worse and it's only because of the top
level down censorship right the
individual doctors they want to share
this and they were sounding the alarm
bells but the you know governance layer
at the top is what is preventing it and
I think if you tie that back into
handshake that's really what handshake
is doing is it's trying to create an
Internet that's not controlled by
governments or organizations at the top
of the hierarchy it's letting the
internet be controlled and literally
owned by individuals yeah and that's
something that we've never had on the
internet before so I'm looking up right
now what the the coronavirus death toll
has surpassed 1,000 people in mainland
China
yeah and that's probably a very
underreported that's probably like yeah
this report like the next 35 minutes ago
is when that was written and so if
that's even remotely a cure it's a big
number and I think a lot of people are
saying it's gonna be underreported
number yeah which is pretty damn sad to
be honest yeah so I guess as you look at
this like what are the next steps here
so handshake we've got the two weeks
where we're gonna get out kind of with
the mining capacity make sure that
that's working people will begin to come
in the first domains that become
available as top-level domains those are
gonna be the less desirable ones the
more desirable a mix it's actually
pretty much equally desirable basically
without getting too much into the weeds
you take any name that you want to bid
on and you hash it to a number and you
take the modulus 52 of that and that
determines which week it is available so
basically is completely random
effectively and each week there's a new
set of names as available and they're
all like pretty good each week and and
it's not like a specific set it's like
any name that you can think of you can
go and bid on it's just at some point
along those 52 weeks so even in this
first week I think like duck coin is
available I'm pretty sure that one's
gonna be pretty popular there's a few
other ones how many names become
available each week it's like a thousand
oh no no it's like a hundred so there's
like 63 characters
that you can use in a domain name so I
was like 26 to the 63 like the namespace
is massive
it basically 1 like 2% effectively of
any name that you can any of the names I
can think of are gonna be available each
week it's not like a 70 thousands each a
million million yeah yeah Wow
and so what happens to the ones that
nobody buys yeah so those are just
unregistered so basically what happens
is until you start the auction process
and you have to submit a specific
transaction to start it that name is
just sitting there and then when you
start it then other people can go and
anyone can start the auction oh I got it
so just because it's available doesn't
mean that it started the actual auction
the first time somebody bids on it then
there's an auction process that starts
and how long does that action last for
ya the auction lasts for five days and
then there's like a 10 day reveal period
it's kind of like a blind adoption
there's some intricacies to it we make
it easier on the name based sigh but
basically you just you have a blind
auction and then there's a 10 day reveal
period where all the participants reveal
their true auction bids and the owner
the winner can claim their name after
that period so the the entire process
was about two weeks got it yeah what
name do you want yeah I want I just want
my my name kishan dot t Shawn yeah dr.
Shawn yeah and also a year my last name
yeah I try to get ya charge on Comm on
the normal internet and there's like a
Chinese company that owns that I'm half
Chinese I want domain company or yeah
it's like the name of their company yeah
so it's just like a big company I don't
think so there's a role on which I can
get that eventually yeah yeah just just
don't matter that you'll help them out
with something yeah I think the best you
know a lot of the people who are
interested you there's this like a new
namespace and there's already a lot of
excitement around it so you can kind of
see like it's kinda like the people who
kind of got into domain name domain
names early on right like they bought
like you know airplane calm or airport
calm and they sort of like millions of
dollars a few years later so people are
speculating component to it yeah there
is and people kind of seed that
potential now right it's like okay the
first time I might miss it but now
there's like a new namespace and there's
like people
very excited it's like the crypto calm
era effectively it's a la people are
trying to get in early and reserve their
personal name early right when it's when
it's still a little bit easier then it
will be even six months from now so
that's you know for me I'll reserve like
da true gear and our you know issue
domain names for each my family members
so I'll be like a really cool thing
because I sell them too
you gonna pay you some other ones but
you know those those are examples where
it's like anyone can benefit from that
right because like who doesn't want
their family name has a TLD I honestly
for someone like the really popular
family names right you imagine like dalu
yeah there's like millions like even
like alien don't lose out there so you
can like if you reserved that one you
start selling them you know you don't
the amazing thing with this is that
normal tio DS take cost millions of
dollars to register first there's a two
hundred thousand dollar application fee
that you pay to I can basically for
doing nothing yeah it sounds like a
racket yeah and then there's like this
like auction system so it cost a lot of
money for two hundred whether you win or
not yes yeah like over a hundred million
off of Jake just application fees it's
pretty ridiculous but if you think about
the costs that they see what that means
is it drastically limits the use cases
of these CL DS right you need to have a
business model that can recoup that cost
however for handshake TL DS you know you
can be registering a name maybe it'll
cost ten thousand maybe cost five
thousand it might even be ten dollars
right he's like so it's just determined
by the second highest price and what
that means is that if you register
something like blue you could just be
selling all those names for like fifty
cents if you sell it to you know hundred
thousand dollars you just made like
fifty thousand dollars yep so it
basically just it's really interesting
thing about all the things that you can
do with these studies once you've
basically had the costs of acquiring
them and lowered it by multiple organs
of matter sued and we'll get to see what
people do with it Joe and I both got
brothers Joe we're gonna buy our last
names and then we're gonna we're not
giving them to our brothers for free
we're making [ __ ] pay us awesome man
all right before we wrap up I asked
rapid-fire questions what is the most
important company in crypto outside of
name base or handshake I think square
crypto
is pretty interesting why they
are introducing a lot of consumers to
crypto where cash is like immensely
popular and I think they're I have to
read the report again but like they're
selling a lot of Bitcoin actually
through oh yeah one hundred plus million
dollars a quarter yeah man they really
appreciate yeah I think I think so
and they get they like understand
consumers right like you if you see
their Twitter like they're really good
at like memes and all that and I think
honestly that's like how things spread
today although I mean I'm personally
very bullish on handshake I think a year
from now most of the people using
handshake won't even know that is
powered by a blockchain they're just
realized that their internet experience
is better effectively and more rich and
more broad so I think handshake is
probably the most exciting thing but if
I wasn't looking at that as a square
crypto is pretty interesting what's the
one regulation or law you would improve
or change if he could yeah I think the
money transmitter laws are pretty and
also like the bit license like that
entire suite of regulation there's a
reason why exists and it's good for some
sort of that to exist but it also is
drastically limiting because the MTL
laws also apply for virtual currency to
virtual currency transactions and that
basically just immensely limits what
companies can do it's a huge hurdle and
other countries in the world don't have
these laws and so these other countries
and citizens are getting access to this
new technology that's really easily and
amazing for them but in the u.s. it's
takes an immense amount of capital to
even get started and navigate that so
that I think that changing would open up
a lot of interesting business models
even like you know cloud Wallis or
custodial solutions that would make
crypto much more adopted that right now
is being limited what is your most
controversial thought in all of crypto
like something you believe that everyone
also disagree with you on I think maybe
not so much a controversial thought but
in terms of what I have conviction
around
I have conviction around Bitcoin and I
have conviction around handshake I don't
have conviction around anything else
nothing you know space and that's not to
say that's not to say that those things
won't succeed right I think as I
mentioned like the history of Silicon
Valley is
people thinking of new technologies as
toys I'll never go anywhere or they
don't they like laugh at it and then it
ends up you know eating the world right
and everyone and everyone ends up using
it so when I don't have conviction and
something is not to say oh I don't think
I think I think it will not succeed it's
just that I don't have conviction that
it will succeed in and I don't have my
belief in that so I think that that is
pretty non-standard of just having only
conviction and those two things what's
the most important book you've ever read
oh there are many I don't I don't think
there's a single book that I could say
is the most I wouldn't like some of the
temper that's you let's see I love
reading stories about how companies got
started so founding sort of eBay the the
perfect store founding sort of Amazon to
everything store founding story of
Walmart Sam Walton made in America those
are all really good books Nikes Nike
founders shoe dog those really good at
you yeah and I think the reason why
those books are important to me is
because as an entrepreneur it's really
hard sometimes right because you have
all this all these bad things happening
all the time and it's really hard to see
like the light forward and then so
reading those stories you also get to
see oh like those people went through
situations like far worse than I'm
experiencing and they were able to
persevere and come out on top that has
been that basically just helping to
build my own conviction is phenomenal
the other book that's really good is the
courage to be disliked it's sound like a
philosophical book I like reading like
philosophy and I read it yeah it was
very very good yeah that would be a good
book to recommend as well aliens
believer non-believer
uh yeah believer why I think it in some
form right I don't think it's like
humans like us or like you know sentient
beating that would be wild if there was
other [ __ ] humans out there and we
didn't know about yeah yeah like I've
asked that question over 200 people no
one said that yet oh really
like what if there was other humans yeah
I mean have you read it the [ __ ]
crazy
have you read the three-body problem
that sounds familiar what it was is like
sci-fi book by CNBLUE it's like a
Chinese sci-fi book but it like it was
no summary but I haven't really
I forget who it was but somebody I think
told me to read this book that's why
it's not familiar that it's a very good
book and it really explores the
implications of if there are other
sentient beings what would happen not
not really good outcomes actually but
that's a pretty a book but yeah I don't
know I don't even really research too
much about like aliens all that so I
wouldn't be able say but I think there's
probably like at least some sort of life
form you're toting around somewhere so
like that's definitely my feeling is
like if there's going to be contact made
we want to be on offense not defense
yeah for sure that's a pretty scary idea
of like us being the ones that are what
is it Independence Day
where the aliens like like there's like
coming out of the sky like what are we
gonna do inside and hide alright what
one question do you have for me to to
finish this up yeah what uh what domains
are you gonna be bidding on I don't know
if I wanted to help people I mean like
there's I would say that there's
probably really obvious ones like it'd
be awesome to own you know dot Bitcoin
right dot crypto those types of things
I'm assuming that there's not the like
doc Google's dot Facebook's domains but
if there were like I'm sure people will
definitely want to grab those to
basically screw around with the Internet
giant's yeah actually the top 100
thousand Alexa domains are already pre
reserved for those companies and
actually that's another conviction point
which is that like if you make it
difficult for those companies to adopt
when they already own those trademarks
then yeah it's just not very gonna go
anywhere
but every other name you can so yeah
it's so dr. Joe is actually one of them
they can get got it okay and then
there's always like the personalized
ones that I think people would want and
then actually I think that there's um
that there's a pretty interesting thing
around if people look at this like a
revenue opportunity right you know
where's the world going and kind of what
domains fit into that well one of the
best stories that I've heard recently
about a domain name so a friend of mine
Brent B Shore
he was having a conversation with a
friend of his patrick O'Shaughnessy and
they used the term permanent equity a
few times and Patrick went home and he
bought the domain well Brent just
changed the name of his firm from
adventures to permanent equity mm-hmm he
now has permanent equity calm because
Patrick had the foresight to kill him
but he just gave it to Brent and so it's
uh it's pretty interesting how like even
in the kind of centralized traditional
world how important URLs are yeah in
these domains and so when you think
about that from a top-level domain or a
second-level domain standpoint if there
is this new namespace you know it's a
pretty important thing for people to to
kind of take seriously and pay attention
to yeah I mean the existing domain name
industry is worth tens of billions of
dollars and they realize how much money
like I think like GoDaddy makes like two
or four billion dollars a year yeah it's
like a stupid amount of money your 1099
purchase of you know whatever stupid com
or.org or whatever they're made for
billion dollars or something like that
yeah yeah so I mean is it anything and I
think what's cool is like handshake
democratizing that economy and allowing
anyone to participate and basically
start their own business and do all that
it doesn't need to be this obscure thing
that a few participants are benefiting
from right now you know everyone can go
and do it so that's really personally
very exciting also man listen where can
uh where can people find you and find
name base yeah we're on twitter at name
base HQ I'm on Twitter at Tish on our
name basis audio is the place to go if
you want to buy H&S or buy handshake
domain names pretty much anything having
to do with the handshake you could
assist some in economy we're gonna try
to build out infrastructure for that's a
good place to go awesome well thanks so
much for coming to do this we'll have to
do it again in a few weeks maybe yeah
totally